est-ce que ça va bien pour vous chez
vous est ce que tout va bien bon vous
l'avez vu dans le titre aujourd'hui on
parle de l'audio et le dj qui envoyait
deux versions de ses 11 derniers
écouteurs les lg tonnes frij et le fp8
et le fp 9,2 produits intéressants voire
un gros focus sur le fp neuf parce que
celui qui est une nouveauté qui va
m'intéresser un petit peu plus c'est le
fp8 que vous avez ici le fp 9 est située
juste là alors c'est vrai que quand on
les regarde comme ça et bien il se
ressemble réellement beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup mais pourtant il ya des vraies
différences entre ces deux produits de
produits intéressants et je voulais tout
de suite j'ai le tarif le fp8 coûte 179
euros et le fp 9 on est à 199 euros et
vous allez voir qu'à ce tarif fort bien
tout cas c'est intéressant on a surtout
des écouteurs qui tiennent très bien
d'une très belle ergonomie on a une très
belle application dans la réduction de
bruit active en un mode transparent
offrant plus on vient éliminer si des
bactéries mais je vais tout vous dire
vous allez tout savoir
regardez déjà ils m'ont envoyé 50 ans
était très sympa j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
aimé l'expérience qu'on va retrouver ici
l'idée en fait cette sodium à regarder
intérieur de votre boîte vous avez quoi
coco coucou monsieur recoux lg de petits
colis différent ça en fait l'idée c'est
de me faire des petites lumières bleues
pour venir illustrer le fait que vous
avez des ultraviolets qui viennent
éliminés jusqu'à 99% de certaines
bactéries on se parle ici des cherry
chaque colis on se parle ici du
staphylococcus aureus mon ce
staphylocoque doré venez voir ici ça la
petite lumière blog vous voyez là ce
n'est pas du tout les ultraviolets parce
que les ultraviolets c'est une longueur
d'onde qu'on ne voit pas avec nos du
donc on peut pas du tout venir les films
et ses histoires vous le montrer c'est
une petit truc assez sympa vous voyez au
fond la salle à ce qui brille un peu
c'est d'ici que partent les ultraviolets
les ultraviolets ils font quoi ils font
un focus sur la grille ici donc ils
viennent nettoyer la grille pour éviter
les infections du goût de votre oreille
une technologie qui est signée lg
intéressant alors on vous me quittent le
meilleur bleu histoire de se dire
regardez je fais une enquête un peu à la
charles ok je vous montre comme ça c'est
ça en fait voyez hein c'est vraiment ce
petit truc là là et je vous le dis une
fois de plus la grille à la elle est là
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là on a beaucoup
de choses à commencer déjà par le
confort alors je vous montre la sur les
fps regardez il ya un truc que j'aime
beaucoup c'est quel pied ils viennent
trouver très très très facilement leur
place en poste comme ça on tourne on le
met et de face regardez c'est quasiment
invisible je dis bien quasiment et en
plus de ça nous avait un truc qui est
assez intéressant ici vous avez le slick
fitz lg qui a collaboré qu'un
laboratoire de technologie de conception
ergonomique renommée qui s'appelle
postec et canaliser des centaines
d'oreilles afin de trouver là justement
parfait pour les vôtres et ce qui fait
que en fait on a un confort qui et ypres
à ypres à ypres agréable vous les prenez
vous les posez et elles sont quasiment
invisibles donc c'est vrai que ça permet
d'avoir des écouteurs qui sont très
légers donc ça s'est super bien en
termes de légèreté on peut y aller on
peut donc si on peut pogoter alors c'est
pas l'idée ici mais si vous voulez faire
du sport avec vous pouvez le faire sans
aucun problème parce qu'ils vont tenir à
vos oreilles ici vous avez un indice
d'étanchéité ipx4 qui va lui apporter de
la résistance à la sueur et aux
gouttelettes donc vous pouvez allez
faire votre sport allait courir sans
aucun problème et yann très très bien et
en plus de ça est ce qui est super bien
regardez ici eh bien vous avez d'autres
en bout que vous allez pouvoir utiliser
pour trouver la taille qui vous
intéressent donc y en a vraiment pour
tout le monde donc que vous ayez des
grandes oreilles des petites oreilles
dans tous les cas vous allez trouver
votre bonheur ici avec vos écouteurs là
vous avez tout un pavé tactile qui vous
permet de venir le commander le contrôle
est très facilement tout ça paramétrable
depuis votre application g vous la
montre dans quelques instants alors
après il ya un autre point qui nous
intéresse ici c'est la qualité audio et
ben oui parce qu'effectivement avoir des
écouteurs c'est bien mais avoir une
bonne qualité c'est quand même autre
chose et c'est vraiment sale but ici
vous avez une très bonne qualité que ce
soit sur l'un ou sur l'autre que vous
allez venir maximiser grâce à un
équaliseur dispo dans l'application je
vais trouver qu'on ait de la ronde il ya
un mode pour venir rajouter des basses
un miro on est davantage mais ici on a
aussi bien de la clarté on a des médiums
qui sont très sympas on va avoir des
bases présentes est ronde et
l'expérience est totalement honnête pour
des écouteurs à 179 ou 199 euros
d'autant plus qu'ici vous avez l'expert
britannique méridian qui vient apporter
sa contribution pour créer une
expérience audio d'excellente qualité ça
c'est vraiment un point fort qu'on va
venir retrouver ici et pour venir goûter
tous styles de musique aussi bien du rnb
aussi bien de l'électro on avoir des
graves profonds on peut avoir également
des sons clairs si on veut écouter du
jazz par exemple tous styles de musiques
confondues vous pouvez les écouter ici
avec vos écouteurs que ce soit le fp8 ou
la fp 9 mais ça ne s'arrête pas là vous
avez la réduction de bruit active
réduction proactive qui est complètement
personnalisable depuis l'application on
va y aller dans cette application parce
que c'est vraiment un élément central de
cette expérience l'application elle
s'appelle comme free vous pouvez
retrouver sur ios mais également sur
android première chose qu'on va voir
c'est effectivement le niveau de forces
que vous avez au niveau de vos écouteurs
mais également des vous de votre étui je
vous ensuite que j'ai le paramètre de
l'école isr je voulais laisser sur
basbous ça fournit un peu plus de
rondeurs mais j'ai bien aimé également
l'expérience avec le tribal boost pour
nous d'écouter de la musique un petit
peu plus fine un peu plus tranquille et
vous avez un truc qui est super
intéressant c'est le 3 décembre staged
qui vous servira lorsque vous allez
venir écouter du sport regarder des
films et des séries ça va apporter en
immersion niveau de vos tongs ça s'est
super bien et après pouvait venir avoir
un réglage que les pouvoir dire
customiser vous éditez et vous modifiez
bandes de fréquences par bandes de
fréquences et je trouve que le réglage
est assez fin après vous avez contrôle
de votre réduction de bruit active une
réduction de bruit qui va être élevé ou
alors une réduction bruit un peu plus
faible à vous de voir en fonction de
l'endroit dans lequel vous êtes et de la
tipp de réduc semble que vous voulez
vous avez ensuite un mode vous allez
tout coupé plus d'électronique pour
trouver avec les écouteurs juste avec
une réduction de bruit pacifique qui
viennent vous boucher les oreilles et
ensuite vous avez une amplification du
son extérieur soit par le son ambiant un
mode écoute qui vous servira lorsque
vous allez venir vous balader par
exemple dans la rue et puis un mode
conversation à ce que voulait parler à
quelqu'un entende et voit un peu plus
clair non ça c'est vachement bien et
après vous avez toute la
personnalisation niveau du palais
tactile que je trouve très très mal il
une fois de plus alors là j'ai laissé
toucher une fois à droite et à gauche
mais ça peut être lecture et c'est peu
dire par exemple une commande vocale si
je veux sur la partie de gauche voyait
sur l'écouteur droit et bien ça va être
une lecture à l'est je peux toucher deux
fois deux fois gauche baisse le volume 2
fois droit je monte le volume est une
fois de plus si quelques réglages pour
bien choisir les six et puis trois fois
ça va être morceau précédent à gauche
morceau suivant à droite et là ils vous
expliquent après vos réglages lorsque
vous allez venir passer un coup de fil
réception d'un appel téléphonique un
appui fin de l'appel deux appuis sur
certains modèles réduction brute active
ici c'est le cas réduction bois qui fait
un appel prolonger réduction bruit
active désactiver réduction collective
activée donc ça c'est vachement bien une
fois de plus tous dans l'application met
à jour logicielle si besoin vous avez en
plus un petit la bbc avec différents
modes qu'on peut venir tester ici vous
allez pouvoir venir cochet activer un
mode jeu qui va réduire la latence ou
des écouteurs lorsque vous allez jouer
différents jus ok ça c'est vachement
bien et vous avez un mode chuchotant
tenez l'écouteur droit près de la bouche
pour parler doucement téléphone les
paramètres de notification qui vous lire
à vos sms vous choisissez en plus si
vous voulez un débit normal ou si vous
voulez un débit rapide loin des bilans
et voilà vous avez tout ce qu'il faut
ici dans cette application je trouve ça
extrêmement pratique parce que vous avez
ici les fonctions essentielles et c'est
tout ce qu'on attend ici d'une
application qui est extrêmement efficace
la réduction proactive quant à elle est
bonne facture elle vient vous isoler du
sort c'est l'électronique ces à bien
manger un petit peu de son si vous
voulez profiter de la meilleure
expérience désactiver tout le mode
transparence et la réduction de bruit
active mais malgré tout lorsque vous
êtes dans les transports en commun ça
fait le taff et ça fait vraiment bien et
il ya un autre truc est super
intéressant qu'on retrouve ici dans le
fp 9 c'est ce qu'on va pouvoir retrouver
avec ce petit câble là et ce petit câble
life un taf qui extraordinaire alors en
fait ça peut paraître un peu gadget
comme ça vous le prenez vous connecter
votre boîtier et vous brancher
un ordinateur vous brancher à une télé
lorsque vous prenez l'avion vous le
branchez dans votre avion et qu'est ce
que ça vient faire eh bien ça fait que
la connexion bluetooth elle va se faire
uniquement entre votre boîtier et les
écouteurs mais là vous allez récupérer
un signal analogique donc ça s'est super
bien imaginez vous êtes dans l'avion
voulez regarder un film vous avez vos
écouteurs vous branchez ça dans l'avion
directement et vous écouter un truc très
facilement de la même manière avec une
télé vous les déranger personne et bien
vous pouvez les utiliser directement là
je peux le faire sur un ordi si je veux
bref la solution elle est vraiment
génial extrêmement pratique ça j'aime
beaucoup et ça vous l'avez uniquement
sur le f p 9 rien que sur le f p 9 et au
niveau des appels qu'est ce que ça dit
me direz vous et bah ça marche bien donc
même pour passer des appels
téléphoniques ici est absolument aucun
problème et vous monter jusqu'à une
autonomie totale de 24 heures jeudi bien
juste car ça va dépendre si vous mettez
de la réduction proactive par réduction
collective et si vous avez peu de temps
en cinq minutes de chaque jour prenez
une heure d'écouté et petite
particularité sur le fp8 sont les seuls
qui ont de la recharge sans fil que vous
n'avez pas sur les fp neuf donc si on
résume on a ici réduction brouille
active on a un super confort et avec des
embouts différents tags permettront à
tout un chacun de trouver la taille qui
lui correspond une très bonne qualité
sonore à que le partenariat avec
méridian sur le fp 9 vous avez la
fonction plug and wireless qui vous
permet d'utiliser une connexion filaire
en bluetooth vous avez trois micros qui
serviront aussi bien pour les appels que
pour la réduction bruit active vous avez
de l'appairage multiples appels
connecter à deux appareils en même temps
uniquement du chargement sans fil sur la
ft-86 vous avez 10 heures d'écouté avec
vos écouteurs et jusqu'à 24 heures avec
boîtier votre application bien
évidemment compatible ios et android et
voulait retrouver dans différentes
couleurs un noir anthracite un blanc
perle est un brume d'or ce que je trouve
vraiment intéressant ici c'est qu'à 179
euros pour l'efs p8 et 199 euros pour le
fp 9 et bien vous avez un produit qui
est extrêmement complet l'application
vous avez tous je vous cache pas que mon
petit coup de coeur ici il vient
vraiment se situer au niveau du confort
de la discrétion et du fait de pouvoir
venir utiliser une connexion filaire
avec des écouteurs sans fil bluetooth et
ça ça plaît beaucoup s'il vous intéresse
vous avez un lien en bas d'un indice qui
sont très très très joli produit signé
lg ici une fois de plus à vous de me
dire vous ce que vous en pensez en bas
oui juste en bas en commentaire et quant
à moi je laisse que je retourne écouter
un peu de musique et là croyez moi c'est
le fera plaisir m un peu de jazz
secousse on se détend on est peinards
vous embrasse a très vite ciao
[Musique]